foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
was a case of decentralized targeting
and a particular faction which initially
claimed the attack broke from the
guidance of the central leadership
another possibility is that even even
though the central leadership signed off
on the attack there's a lot of backlash
from Pakistan as well as perhaps from
the the Taliban in Afghanistan due to
which they have disowned this attack a
third possibility is that this is all a
drama a charade the central leadership
of the TDP is using this Rogue faction
to conduct such mass casualty attacks
and then ultimately disassociating
themselves after seeing how people react
to it
[Music]
foreign